guest in the realm we got to do the
tradition you know what I'm saying so I
need more Chris ray guns I think I know
one of these the answer to one of these
but I need to hear it live your top five
video games or franchises of all time
and why
oh wow okay so
top top five okay you take a singular
video game or you could take a franchise
I'm not gonna do franchise that's that's
the easy way that's super odd yeah yeah
Shadow Colossus is is my number one it's
it's always been I love I love Shadow
the closet I think that game's just
beautiful I'm playing it again actually
uh I started again last night and I just
I forgot how gorgeous that thing is the
Remake is crazy yeah the Remake is it's
wonderful it looks amazing but that's a
game that's crazy because I remember
playing shot of the glasses in 2013 on
the PS3 like the upres version that was
the first time that was the first time I
played it and it blew my mind and then
yes like way after the scale of the
Colossus